foreign
yes and the reason why is the Democrats
have failed the American public with the
highest inflation we've had in more than
40 years your gas prices that you have
never seen like this before crime in our
streets and a border that's wide open
that now has fentanyl to be the number
one killer of Americans between the ages
of 18 and 45. if we take the majority
we will make sure we lower the cost of
energy and become energy independent we
secure our streets to be safe and then
more importantly we secure our border at
the same time we give the parents a Bill
of Rights to have a say in their kids
education I don't know the exact number
but we're going to try to win every
single one possible let me give you one
good example just in the last month we
want a seat in a special election in a
seat that Joe Biden won by 13 points
that is 84 percent Hispanic the second
most Hispanic seat in the country and
the Republican have not held that seat
in more than a hundred years and
congresswoman Myra Flores who's never
run for office before she proved she
could do it based upon securing our
border based upon making America energy
independent so your gasoline price gets
lower we lower inflation parents have a
say in their kids education
the streets become safe again with that
type of idea that we can win in a seat
like that I think we could have a really
really big red wave we will hold this
Administration accountable we'll make
sure the Attorney General can't go after
parents for going to a school board
meeting we will have hearings on where
covet originated we will have hearings
on what happened in Afghanistan that
created 13 more gold star families to
make sure
you know what I would look at I would
look at a race in Rhode Island I would
look at some of the New York seats you
haven't seen before I would look at
California I'd look at Nevada I'd look
at Oregon and there is places clear
across this country that I think you're
going to see races you haven't seen
before where an exciting new candidate I
think the extremism on the Democratic
side has pushed people away from their
party yes it shows on registration just
in the last year the party switches
overwhelmingly switching to the
Republican party they want to see a
party that reflects puts people before
politics and that's exactly what the
Republican party is doing we will have a
commitment to America